in 1997 director paul verhoeven adapted
the story's starship troopers from
robert heinlein's novel
the mega budget film was a total flop
and panned by the critics
if you want to learn more about this
crazy misunderstood satire
here's the ending of starship troopers
explained
the story is set in the distant future
when earth is ruled by a fanatical
government that requires military
service as a condition for full
citizenship
despite that life seems relatively
prosperous
apart from a series of ongoing battles
with giant alien insects known as the
bugs
our heroes are four recent high school
graduates who enlist in the military for
various reasons
carmen played by denise richards dreams
of becoming a pilot
carl a young looking neil patrick harris
is an academic prodigy with leighton's
psychic
abilities who ends up in military
intelligence
casper van dien plays johnny rico a
nameless jock in search of his identity
he impulsively enlists in an effort to
impress carmen his girlfriend
but ends up in the most dangerous branch
of the military
the infantry then dizzy played by deena
meyer
joins the same unit as johnny hiding an
unrequited crush on him
then the bugs launch a direct attack on
earth destroying our hero's hometown of
buenos aires
buenos aires has been wiped off for
europe humanity responds by launching a
direct invasion
on the bug homeworld of clindathu but
this operation ends up being a complete
disaster
100 000 soldiers die in the first hour
alone
including most of rico's unit rico and
dizzy are some of the only survivors and
get transferred to an elite group of
soldiers known as the roughnecks
led by the stoic lieutenant rajak played
by michael ironside
soon after rico dizzy and the roughnecks
are on their way to answer a distress
call on a world
only known as planet p it's here that
the film's final chapter begins
our heroes arrive on planet p and
discover that the soldiers who sent them
the distress signal have all been killed
they find only a lone survivor a general
who explains his forces have discovered
an unknown group of bugs called brain
bugs that have the ability to absorb
knowledge by feasting on the minds of
humans
the bugs then attack the base and many
roughnecks are killed
including lieutenant rajek and dizzy i'm
done
i'm dying however rico and several
others are saved by a passing ship
piloted by carmen rico has given command
to the roughnecks and his old buddy carl
tasks him with another operation we're
going back to p
to capture that brain however carmen's
ship is suddenly hit by an explosive
plasma projectile
she crash lands on planet p and is
captured by the bugs
she's then brought before the elusive
brain bug who's hungry for the young
pilot's tasty grey matter
but rico and a couple other roughnecks
arrive at the last minute and save her
johnny and carmen retreat to the surface
and moments later
they find that the brain bug has been
captured carl arrives on the scene and
uses his psychic powers to sense its
emotions
he declares it's afraid
[Music]
it's afraid the surrounding soldiers
cheer
and the film ends with a military
recruitment video
encouraging the audience to join the
fight against the bugs
after humanity's victory on planet p
it's probably safe to assume that johnny
carmen and carl are all locked into a
lifetime in the military
after the destruction of buenos aires we
doubt they'll ever return to the lives
they had before
they can't go home again both in a
literal and metaphorical sense
the final recruitment ad gives us a
chance to check in on our heroes one
last time
rico has been given permanent command to
the roughnecks
carmen has achieved her dream of
becoming a starship captain
and carl was president the first ever
capture of a brain bug so we can only
imagine the promotions that await him
in the future but are rico and carmen
going to get back together
the film ends with their relationship
status uncertain they each had romantic
adventures while apart
carmen with her crewmates xander and
rico with dizzy
but now both of their would-be paramours
are deceased but there was an alternate
ending that settled things far more
definitively
in this scrapped version of the finale
rico and carmen celebrate their victory
on planet p
with a kiss reaffirming their romantic
relationship
when carmen's ship crash lands on planet
p she radios johnny
telling him there are bugs closing in
all around her
rico hesitates for a moment before
ordering the roughnecks to ignore her
distress call and continue onward
he knows that the bugs don't take
prisoners a few minutes later rico stops
in his tracks and says
she's still alive how do you know
i don't know how i know but i know it
turns out that rico's hunch is correct
carmen is indeed alive as the prisoner
of the brain bug
and rico manages to rescue her but how
did rico do this
we know that psychic powers exist in the
world of starship troopers
but rico definitively doesn't have them
the film does actually offer a potential
explanation to rico's lucky hunch in its
closing moments
but it's easy to miss when rico finally
reunites with carl at the end of the
film
a new possibility occurs to him he says
to carl
it was you wasn't it you told me how to
find carmen
all carl says in return is well that's
classified
it seems that carl's psychic powers much
like his military rank
had risen to heights he never would have
thought possible
on a basic level starship troopers isn't
a difficult movie to understand
there's not much ambiguity in the ending
nor are there any last minute plot
twists but on a deeper thematic level
it's a surprisingly tough film to pin
down and easy to misinterpret
in one sense it's just a movie about
soldiers killing bugs without really
telling the audience how to feel about
it
because of this when the film was first
released it was panned for being
violent joyless and empty we totally get
how this happened
there's no big speech at the end where
our main character says
i was wrong war is bad the humans and
bugs don't discover that they aren't so
different after all
and decide to make peace honestly no one
really learns anything in the end
that's not to say that the film doesn't
have a point that it's trying to make
it actually has several but these
characters in this world are so far
gone that there's no saving them they
can't learn the lesson but
we can starship troopers is a cautionary
tale
trying to steer us away from the
horrible future this film depicts
one of the topics that starship troopers
seems interested in exploring is the
idea of self-delusion
all throughout the film single-minded
obsession and willful ignorance
lead to the characters either dying or
ruining their lives
the humans believe that the bugs are
weak and that victory on clindathu is
assured but then the bugs slaughter
them mercilessly and they're forced to
retreat humans think that the bugs are
unintelligent but at the end of the film
they discover the intelligent brain bugs
time and again
the humans end up being completely wrong
but this theme isn't just explored on a
cosmic scale
it's also reflected in the lives of our
heroes rico's all-consuming love for
carmen makes him enlist in the infantry
which forces him to endure
life-threatening horrors
dizzy's obsession with rico leads her to
request a transfer to his unit
which ultimately leads to her death
starship troopers shows us that many of
the horrible things that happen to us
are things that we do to ourselves out
of pride
one of the central themes of starship
troopers is a critique of fascism
fascism is a somewhat loose concept
describing a range of different
political movements united by how they
gain and maintain control
in his 1995 essay philosopher umberto
echo
lists 14 qualities of fascism these
qualities include a rejection of arts
and the humanities
a need to exist in a state of perpetual
warfare propaganda
and a tendency to characterize their
enemies as both quote horrible threat
that will destroy us all
and no match for our superior military
might
echo states that fascist governments are
condemned to lose wars because they are
constitutionally incapable of
objectively evaluating the force of the
enemy
you may notice that many of the tenets
of fascism seemingly contradict one
another
and you'd be correct at the end of the
day starship troopers shows that fascism
is anti-intellectual
as exemplified by pretty much every
character in the film
and is a system that definitely deserves
ridicule
perhaps a major reason why critics
initially labeled starship troopers as
feeling brainless and soulless
is because of how often our heroes have
to face horrifically grim tragedies
with no warning and with seemingly no
deeper meaning
buenos aires is destroyed by a meteor
killing rico's parents
during a training exercise a perfectly
nice farm boy gets accidentally shot in
the head
and the woman who accidentally shoots
him a kind person with dreams of
becoming a politician has her entire
career destroyed in an instant
is the film just doing this for cheap
shock value what are we supposed to make
of all this senseless suffering
there's an argument to be made that
starship troopers is a work of
existential nihilism
the french philosopher jean-paul sartre
said that we live in a world without a
god
where everything comes into existence
empty of meaning
basically stuff just happens and it
doesn't mean anything
the idea that war and by extension life
is meaningless
is a common theme in war movies
happiness or a sense of purpose only
occurs in glimmers
such as executing the perfect play to
win the high school football game
dancing with your squad mates as a
soldier plays the violin
or spending the night with your
sweetheart before a big battle
when everything seems meaningless hold
on to your friends and enjoy what time
you have with them
because that's all you have in the end
the book and the film versions of
starship troopers share many of the same
character names and plot beats but
they're wildly different
in terms of their priorities and deeper
messages
the book spends most of its time inside
of johnny rico's head as he muses about
life while at boot camp but the movie is
more of an ensemble piece and focuses on
the war itself
also the soldiers in the novel have
powered armor exoskeletons but trying to
replicate all of these imaginary set
pieces on screen
may have been a bit advanced for a film
to handle back in 1997.
in fact verhoeven wasn't a fan of the
book at all in an interview with empire
he said quote
it is really quite a bad book he then
went on to say about
his cinematic adaptation all the way
through we were fighting with the
fascism
the ultra militarism all the way through
i wanted the audience to be asking
are these people crazy if you can't get
enough starship troopers then we have
some good news
and some bad news the good news is that
the end of this film
isn't the end of the story as there are
numerous direct to video sequels the bad
news
they are not that great the first two
sequels are direct to video live action
films starship troopers 2 heroes of the
federation
is pretty much universally disliked it
doesn't feature any returning characters
and it doesn't have any of the satiric
self-awareness of the original film
starship troopers 3 marauder however is
more of a return to form
not only because casper van dien returns
to reprise his role as
johnny rico but because the filmmakers
once again achieve a satiric tone
more in line with the first installment
it's a bit of a step down in quality
from the first movie in pretty much all
respects
but it's still totally worth a watch for
die hard fans
after the third movie the franchise
switched over to the world of animation
starship troopers invasion wasn't
especially loved by critics and it was
compared unfavorably to a bad video game
cut scene
and finally starship troopers trader of
mars
received some lukewarm praise for being
a campy fun time
but it's still paled in comparison to
the original film
on the plus side not only does casper
van deen return to voice rico and
traitor of mars but this time deena
meyer
also returns to provide the voice for
dizzy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you